hey everyone this is stephen with
collider i am thrilled that uh that
henry is here to talk about wendell and
wild i love your work i'm so excited for
people to see this movie um
what are you
you've worked on a number of stop-motion
films each
unique but with your own style and i'm
just curious what are you most excited
for your fans to see with your newest
work i just think uh tonally
this is its um
own world it has a lot to do with uh
partnering with jordan peele as a
co-creative
uh he was a producer and co-writer and
uh
his input
is the flavors he's added are uh really
wonderful and that's
oh a whole little closer
that's that's what uh
it's very unique i think tonally it
really straddles a line between comedy
horror fantasy and drama
it's all those things at various moments
you know i'd like to think people will
it'll be a little bit a little bit of a
challenge and and that they'll take
something away from it well one of the
things that i found so
cool and great about the movie is that
it's a completely different type of
story than you've done before and than
anything i've ever seen in stop motion
um can you sort of talk about that
aspect of the film
um because of the fantastical elements i
did want to anchor
the reality in actual real things not
going too heavy-handed but
a couple of social issues that matter to
me and i thought would be a little bit
of the bedrock of our story
um as far as like who the real villains
are when there's monsters in a film you
assume it's monsters but no humans are
always going to be the worst
of the villains no 100 i actually think
when i was watching the film and when it
was over what struck me was this is a
film that like walt disney would have
never made and i just i just didn't
believe that they would get behind it
and i really want to commend netflix for
making the movie because i think that uh
that it deals with real stuff in the
movie and i anyway i think netflix's
streaming i think allowed this movie to
have to happen do you agree with that
totally agree um you know we didn't
jordan and i didn't go out to that many
places to pitch it because we knew it
was not
going to work for me mainstream
animation studios
netflix was the place that said we don't
just say we're going to make a film
if we love you and your idea we will
make it and they held true to their word
took a little extra time we had some
delays with covin and so forth but
you're right i don't think any other uh
studio would have backed us
um as fully as netflix so one of the
things that i find so fascinating when
i'm watching a stop-motion movie because
everything is so
um it's so challenging to make a
stop-motion movie that um when you move
the camera how long a shot is going to
last all of these things require so much
pre-planning and deciding where you're
going to spend your time so can you talk
a little bit about as a director
when you make those decisions when you
want to have an extended shot and when
you want the camera to move in an
extended shot those kinds of filmmaking
decisions um you always start off just
from
pure creativity and you storyboard
everything to death just like most
animated films and many live-action
films
you pre-plan everything you make the
movie twice
uh once in storyboards where you edit it
together with with voice temp music and
so forth
but then there's the reality of
translating it what is it actually going
to take to shoot something um so it's
always uh very fluid
um
with a few exceptions there's a few
places where you need
a grand shot
you need to put in the time to have a
camera sweep in circle around
move in close those become
you know sort of like
key moments for the film to be big and
have a large feeling so everywhere else
you can compromise
um
you can throw out reaction shots you're
i mean you're always
every week it's it's throwing out shots
adding combining
but you kind of go
here here here here these have to be
grand and big and we're not
compromising so you just you just sort
of look at what's in the schedule and
make room for those shots
where you the movie really needs them to
be grand when people watch the film
which shot ended up being the one that
gave you nightmares or the one that gave
animators nightmares to actually pull
off and how long did it actually take to
do it
well um
the first big shot
actually is one i already
mentioned it's it's um when uh
cat who's our protagonist
goes to a graveyard and hopes to summon
her parents
back and uh it is a big long shot
with her new friend in the background
circling around a storm rises up
there's supernatural elements
um it it
it was the first big shot it took weeks
and weeks and weeks at the rate we were
going we were never going to get the
movie done but
it just took that long for everyone to
get in tune with each other you know um
i've worked with a lot of the same folks
in these movies but every movie has its
own demands so that was our tune-up shot
it was probably the longest most
complicated shot
nightmares um yeah we all had nightmares
it wasn't just the animators it was
simply
all these things had to come together
but it was our testing ground our
proving ground to get in tune with each
other and how to pull these off but yeah
it was
forever i can't remember how many weeks
um from beginning to end for people that
don't realize what it really takes to
make a stop-motion movie how long ago
did you actually start on this project
once you sort of once netflix said we're
going to make this um we actually did a
a a test for netflix they said we're
going to make it but we want you to do a
test scene
and that was
four
four years ago and we we actually i
decided as long as we're gonna do a test
we should test something that could end
up being in the movie because it was
gonna be as laborious as making the real
film so we did something pretty
elaborate built real puppets a real set
and uh it was almost uh
four years and four or five months ago
that we
went into production the test
and um
they loved it and ninety percent of the
test is in the film it it's it was you
know that was always the plan like don't
waste our time let's make something
that's gonna be in the movie it's i
think people don't realize like making
uh
not a normal movie but a dif you know a
real like a no real a narrative film
that doesn't involve stop motion uh i
mean you could conceivably get it all
done in a few months but usually it's
like a year and i i don't think people
fully realize like as you said four
years and months to make something like
this at any point though as a filmmaker
because i've spoken to a lot of
directors and they talk about when
they're testing like a comedy how
they'll have seen the joke so many times
that they almost think it's not funny
anymore and they need to be reminded at
a test screening or showing it to new
people oh it's still funny at any point
during the process when you're spending
this much time on something do you start
like second and third guessing yourself
that a sequence that you originally
thought was so good is just not as good
as you remember it
um
i'd call one of my greatest strengths
the ability to go from the macro view to
micro back and forth
and normally i'm pretty good but this
one took longer than any other film and
i did start to lose it i did get to a
point where i felt like it's too slow
it's too slow we got to cut i i
could have damaged
the film badly
but i had people around me who i trusted
to say no it's fine you're just you're
too used to it
um
i actually don't mind that it takes a
long time in these films because it's i
just think that's how we get our best
ideas and refine those ideas we get to
live with them a long time so that's
what i love
um but yeah there was danger especially
in this film because of it
another year
longer than anything else i'd worked on
uh talk a little bit about having jordan
peele as a partner um obviously this is
his first time working in this format
working with you uh what did you take
away from working with him and that sort
of like surprised you or just could you
talk a little bit about the
collaboration well it started off in a
good place because he was a huge fan of
stop-motion animation i mean
i i went to him and his former comedy
partner king michael key
because i wanted some of what they do so
well in my films i'm not known for
comedy there's comedic moments but i
wanted something unique uh and more
but he wanted to contribute more and it
turned out he loves stop-motion in fact
the logo for his company monkey paw
productions is beautiful stop-motion
animation so it's it's not like a hobby
he loves it he knows about it
uh i think he he knows what his
strengths are
so it wasn't um so much he had to get in
tune with it he kind of understood it
it was more simply about the tone of the
film
uh the nature the humor
who these characters were
what he
how he imagined the film being and so
many of his ideas
were fresh and better and
i embraced them
you have some very eccentric characters
uh in the film and i'm just could you
talk a little bit about um maybe if you
have a favorite or just or you know
creating these kinds of characters in
stop motion well i mean as far as the
eccentric characters um
sure we've got plenty uh i think um for
the eccentric ones it's uh
manberg the merciless who's a janitor
but who also collects demons
he's uh kind of unique
in all the world and um
later on in another interview i'll tell
you about his origin story it's very
interesting
father best
who is voiced by james hung
is one of my favorites james hong who's
over 90 years old
had so much creativity and vitality that
he brought to this uh
insane uh
headmaster of this private girls school
um
you know
eccentric characters um
those are probably my my tops there but
i love all the characters i think that
we
we did a great job at um
nailing down very specifics who these
people are and jordan was a huge hand in
our lead certainly him and what keegan
michael key brought to um the two demon
brothers
who are the um antagonists uh to the
protagonists
um of cat who's voiced by lyric ross and
she
there'd be no cat with that lyric
she totally by the second session she
was telling me
no cat wouldn't say that and i would ask
well how would she say it and she'd
always know
um anyway i'm
there's no characters i don't love you
gotta love them all completely one of
the things about um most movies in
hollywood is that there is oftentimes an
extensive test screening process because
and you can make revisions and you alt
or whatever um but with stop motion i
would imagine it's a completely
different process because well it's stop
motion um how does it actually work in
terms of
when you made this did netflix want you
to test certain versions along the way
or do you like can you sort of talk
about the process with stop-motion and
testing yeah i'm uh in my past
we never tested um
i would test i mean i would show it to
people i trusted and get feedback and
make sort of adjustments in this case we
kind of didn't do any testing until we
were finished and then we did one
important
um
task you know different age groups
netflix has
has the means to to
connect with all sorts of audiences
and the main thing we we found was um
what was working for different age
groups
and i was very pleased that it's
it's a pg-13 film which is something
jordan and i insisted on just so we had
the freedom
to go those places if we needed to
although we
we barely do it's not it's not
especially terrifying or violent or foul
or any of those things but um
what we learned was
that people loved it
the most universally were like 10 to 14
year olds which is always a theory of
mine
kids always want to see something
older that they have drawn to that but
we made we made some good adjustments
just clarifying simplifying shifting
some scenes around
reordering things just to make it a
little less challenging
for uh the broader audience based on the
feedback so it was it was
it was kind of last minute but it was
very critical and i think all the
adjusts
really helped the film yeah it's
interesting because i
i've spoken to so many people and they
talk about like the test screening
process and the pros and cons and stuff
but ultimately um you're the it's a
tricky endeavor because you're making
art and the art has to be paid for and
you want people to enjoy it and it's one
of these like you know what i mean
there's the best is when art and
commerce meet right in the middle and
it's just you know one of those perfect
marriages
yeah i mean you want the film to be
i always knew the film would work and
that in time
it would definitely find an audience
it's better to find them sooner
so that a company like netflix will
continue to take chances
you know they it's
the best thing about netflix is that we
don't have to live and die opening
weekend
as you do in traditional releases
but they
it does matter
a lot you know they they know who's
watching and how many are watching and
so
if it doesn't hurt the film i'm happy to
make
the sort of adjustments
that might help that audience uh
appreciate it the first time around a
little more easily it's so funny because
uh netflix so no longer are you thinking
about the opening weekend box office now
it's all about am i in the top 10 movies
on netflix for like the first you know
week or month or whatever it may be you
know that's the only thing now i'm sure
that you're thinking about i i am
thinking about that and it's also
features versus series with series
people have time to get to know the
characters and they get invested
and features we don't get that same kind
of time it's like you got to grab them
right away get people to care about them
right away
so it's a very different process
uh completely i want to ask you a few
different questions if you don't mind
that uh if you you've obviously been
very fortunate you've been able to make
movies and you obviously got netflix to
make this film but is there a project
that you have developed over the years
that you actually struggled or have
still struggled with trying to get the
financing like what is there anything
out there that if you could get the
financing for you would make it tomorrow
well i actually had a film underway
after coraline which was uh
i'm very proud of the film it was
successful i set up a deal with pixar
and disney to develop something and
developed several films the one that we
actually got underway and into early
production was called the shadow king
and there was a reshuffle a guy named
alan horn came in
and for a variety of reasons
the main one was that
john lasseter couldn't quite
leave us alone because we were in a
lower budget film
and you know as long as we could keep it
in that range they were happy
but you know because of who he is and
how he works
he just couldn't help changing it and
changing and changing it and the budget
started to go up and up and up and we
reached a point where they were just
uncomfortable and they they shut it down
so um
i did get the rights back um
and maybe i'd go back to that film and
make it the right way
and uh but there's other other projects
as well i've i have a favorite project
another neil gaiman project
which is um
you know it's the osha at the end of the
lane it's been set up to be live action
several times but i had one opportunity
to do stop motion with him before and uh
unless i hear otherwise from neil i
think i still had opportunities well i
think it's his best book
and
he also would love to do another
stop-motion film with me the other thing
is a the track record between the two of
you is uh f and great and b i feel like
all of a sudden and maybe i'm just wrong
about this but i feel like all of a
sudden neil's like his work is starting
to just get out there more over the last
few years with good omens with the
sandman finally getting made and um
maybe that can help uh oh it totally
neil learned the more he's involved the
better
the work turns out to be
so that's it started with good omens and
then sandman
and uh
and so yes he's a filmmaker now in the
past it was sort of like
weighing in and but not being really as
much in charge
but with him in charge his stuff is more
successful and yeah he's um
he's become a powerhouse in in uh
streaming series
i think the sandman is phenomenal also
on netflix everyone which you already
know but it's just so great of a series
yeah i can't wait for them to announce
its second season have you heard
anything i was just going to ask you um
what's so interesting and i just had
this conversation with other people is
it is the most it's been in the top 10
since it came out yeah and yet they have
not announced the second season yet and
it's really making me crazy because it's
so popular and it's so good that i'm
like please like make more you know it's
me too they've got their team they're
just
waiting for the go yeah i i need it to
happen i i actually think people will be
very pissed if they don't make more
because it was so it's so good um but
anyway if someone has actually never
seen anything you've done before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why
i'm hoping that that they'll
be willing to take a chance that it's
going to be a mix of something they know
and something they've never seen before
i try to give a few anchor points and
hand holds to take him on a journey but
i want to hit him up with
something brand new something original
but here's my question of your previous
films is there one that someone should
start with first
ah you know i'm for different reasons i
i would say
coraline is first because it's more me
and um
and of course nightmare before christmas
it's tim burton and myself and danny
elfman
um
but uh you know that's the order i would
prefer
what is it
i'm so curious because obviously when
everyone knows how much nightmare before
christmas what when it first came out
the reaction and what's happened over
the many years
what is it like for you
now
with the
how
much it's in the popular culture and how
many people have seen it and what goes
on at disneyland every halloween and
everything about that film
it's i mean it's remarkably
wonderful to be a part of a project that
has
such long legs such a long life
it was uh you know it was seen as one
thing
originally it was uh we got to make
exactly the movie we wanted there was no
real interference
at all tim was the godfather he had a
great story and the songs are wonderful
but we got to make the movie we wanted
and it came out had a certain amount of
success seemed to
disappear it was sad but then it
stuff started to bubble up and then
they started to make more merchandising
and more and more and eventually disney
stopped calling it a touchstone movie
and it became an official disney film
exactly they realized this could be
disney too look it's sold over a billion
dollars worth of merchandising and it's
still selling so
nothing better than a feeling of uh you
know for years i'd be the stay-at-home
guy when our grown sons were little
going out for trick-or-treating and the
kids would come by
and there was more and more kids dressed
up and nightmare before christmas uh
character costumes
and um
you know if their parents were with them
i'd say hey i got something to show you
and i'd lead him in and show him jack
skellington on the sled
with all the reindeer and zero up front
because i have that in my house and
they'd scream with delight
um nothing better
started out with coraline too it's it's
had uh it has a following and it's
starting to grow
uh leica isn't disney so they don't
quite know how to
how to handle it and manage it but i i
think they may may figure it out one of
the things that disney has done recently
is created all of these kind of short
films more shorts based on some of their
popular movies and characters especially
for disney plus and i'm so curious have
you ever thought about
revisiting nightmare before christmas or
any of those characters
for a short for like at halloween or
christmas whether it be like a musical
number or this is me spitballing but i'm
just curious if the conversation has
ever come up
the idea of a short has never come up in
the past
um you know a sequel had come up several
times
and
initially they always said but it will
have to be cg
and that was a non-starter for me it
certainly was for tim burton
um
i think that
tim might be open to a short but he's
pretty much been against
a sequel he just you know i and i agree
that it worked out and it would have to
be
so refreshing something such a new take
to justify making a sequel but a short
makes good sense well that and i say
this as a fan i agree that when you
i love nightmare before christmas like
everyone watching i mean i i was gonna
curse but i often love it and i don't
want you guys to make a sequel unless it
would be amazing but i i would love to
see a short because i don't feel like
you know what i mean like that could
explore just a little moment and just
get like a taste like you know seeing
your friends again yeah maybe
a short that that's a about zero how his
viewpoint of the world or a day in his
life
uh i think that's a fantastic idea and
doable
i predict tim would back that
uh so i'm really hoping that this seed
that i planted gets germinated because i
do think and that's another thing even
with coralline you know like seeing a
character or you know what i mean you're
revisiting they do that for a lot of
different projects especially now with
disney plus and the streaming services
and you know um and i think we even
premiered
a leica
like a halloween like a holiday
thing that they animated with some of
the characters like at a holiday party
where it was like all the characters
from their movies sitting at a table or
something and i loved it you know just
seeing them
i'm in favor sounds good right as i as i
ramble on about this i'm so sorry um uh
is there an ip that you have always
looked at from afar that you would love
and i'm not talking about neil gaiman
stuff but is there any ip from afar that
you've looked at and said i would really
like to play in that world oh there's
been
various things um
you know certainly i always thought the
adams family uh world could work
beautifully in stop-motion animation
though
i will say from what i've seen of tim
burton's
take on
wednesday
i'm shocked in a the best possible way i
think it might be the best thing he's
been involved with in years you know
it's live action but my god are they
they're going for the real hardcore
charles adams dark humor in it so um
as far as myself there's um
nothing else i'd care to mention right
now there's things i've been intrigued
by um other
oh roll doll stories you know for y for
years i always thought the bfg would
have worked best as a stop lotion
film but you know things come and go and
they get
they get made um
so nothing else to uh to share at the at
this moment you have any any ideas for
me
sir i nothing i can suggest that uh
you've priority not thought about my
last question for you today um
obviously you have been working
tirelessly on wendell and wild but you
know the journey of making that film is
almost over after you're done promoting
have you already thought about what you
might do next or are you taking a long
vacation
i think i'm gonna take a good a good
break um
you know we um
made the video in portland oregon just
just like we uh
did with coraline it's kind of the
center step motion animation now
guillermo made his film like soldiers on
uh but my home base is in northern
california
so reacclimating
and we have to see how it does it it'll
be one of those
if um
the world responds uh favorably strongly
then it's uh open question maybe maybe
you know i'll get back to doing
something else but it's a wait and see
i i completely understand um well i will
say that uh
uh i'm so thankful that you made the
movie i want to thank again netflix for
making the movie because um i know it's
not you know it's more not challenging
material but more adult material if you
will uh you know there's anyway i'm not
going to say too much more i'm just
going to say you should definitely seek
it out definitely watch it thank you so
much for coming in i wish you nothing
but the best thank you so much i'm i'm
glad to i'm glad you apparently liked
the film
and i hope the world does as well and uh
i i share your appreciation netflix
they stuck with us through some very
tough times and we got to the end i am
very appreciative of what they have done
thank you so much for coming in
you